allez voir ce qui était le bras séculier
de ben ali et flic opportuniste ou
sincère ils ont viré casaque
enfin ils apprennent à parler plutôt qu
à matraquer il m'embarque pour me
conduire dans un quartier difficile de
tunis s'est pas encore le grand amour
mais chacun veut y croire nous sommes
annila les jeunes ne fut plus en voyant
débarquer les cowboys et on préfère se
serrer les mains plutôt que de se casser
mais ça n'empêche les habitants du
quartier chômeurs pour la grande
majorité égrènent leurs malheurs moi je
fais partie des personnes auxquelles on
a coupé l'électricité
je vais t'expliquer pour que tu
comprennes moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
ta sécurité ton confort et celui ta
famille et pas l'eau ou l'électricité
la caméra est un catalyseur de la parole
une opportunité de plus pour s'exprimer
vous pensez que les policiers ont encore
changé leur comportement
il y à des policiers qui sont bien que
dieu les protège
mais il y en a d'autres qui ne mérite
pas d'être au ministère de l'intérieur
ce sont des voyous ce sont des voyous
mais ce ne sont pas des serviteurs de
l'état
toi tu as déjà des problèmes qui au
chômage étaient tranquillement assis
dans un café ils viennent ils te tabasse
pourquoi pourquoi ni respect ni rien du
tout ce qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce
qu'est née la raison numéro 2 millions
d'euros maintenant
maintenant tout a changé oui mais tout a
changé
ah je veux mon comportement et plus et
vélizy que d'autres le voient maintenant
ce sera vrai sofiane tout a changé c'est
plus comme avant aujourd'hui on parle
plus comme avant c'est plus pareil
location à marrakech bol c'est plus
comme avant c'est comme ce que tu viens
de dire je viens pas d'agresser ou de
frapper n'est ce pas dealer entre la
police maintenant quand ils font leur
travail on les aide
patton nous embêtent plus ils ne
viennent plus nous agresser pour rien
sans motif traité ta mère ta soeur
compères ta famille te persécutés te
frapper et ans plus tard était entre moi
et mon frère il y a un lien fort
maintenant avec lui et le pouvoir qu'il
représente est depuis toujours j'ai peur
quand je vois un uniforme
j'ai peur maintenant et maintenant et
maintenant ça va juste dix mois c'est
une fraternisation pour la télévision ou
c'est une brève nous l'ont fait
ces images datent du 28 décembre dernier
ça semble une éternité quand on regarde
le raz-de-marée qui en quelques semaines
a eu raison de cet homme pendant 23 ans
il a étouffé son peuple ici il vient au
chevet de mohamed bouazizi celui qui
s'est immolé pour protester contre la
police lorsqu'elle est venue lui
confisquer sa charrette de fruits et de
légumes bouazizi est mort quelques jours
plus tard son sacrifice a déclenché un
ouragan de liberté en tunisie et dans
tout le monde arabe
la jeunesse s'est soulevée dans tout le
pays
[Applaudissements]
ben ali à ordonner une fois de plus la
répression 67 morts mais les gavroches
tunisiens ont tous peur
l'armée les rejoint ben ali aux abois
promet tout la baisse des prix la fin de
la censure
il annonce qu'il partira en 2014 en ce
qui concerne vos revendications
comme je voulais dit je vous ai compris
causses toujours
laliberté n'attend pas le slogans fusent
devant le ministère de l'intérieur
ben ali dégage pour tuer le pape elle
dégage toi honnête on a battu promesses
dimanche
[Applaudissements]
la peur a changé de camp le dictateur
sans fui en arabie saoudite le 14
janvier au soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a eu des pillages bien sûr des
affamés qui se sont servis sur la bête
sur les temples de la consommation
auquel la majorité n'avaient pas accès
en d'autres temps et ailleurs on aurait
dit récupération prolétarienne mais les
destructions sont restées limitées
le 27 février béji caïd essebsi devient
premier ministre de transition le temps
que le pays d' écervelés s'organise que
des partis se forme que les tunisiens
réapprennent la politique et ce premier
ministre là c'est qu'avant tout il faut
redonner aux tunisiens la sécurité d'un
gouvernement provisoire et lorsque vous
avez pris vos fonctions très vite
vous avez dit ma priorité c'est de
restaurer la sécurité
ou est-ce que vous en êtes et je suis
fier de constater que les gens m'ont
fait confiance dès le début ils sont
partis d'eux-mêmes sans contrainte
chacun a regagné sa région d'origine
vite on m'a fait passer un message que
j'ai vite compris
nous avons fait confiance on vous
donnera un préjugé favorable nous disent
je vais pas là c'est un engagement fort
et c'est une responsabilité importante
parce que je sais par expérience que la
confiance c'est quelque chose fragile et
je travaille là dessus
ou justement à rétablir complètement de
la sécurité parce qu'il n'ya pas de
sécurité tant que les gens n'avaient pas
à manger à leur faim mais de trouver du
travail
[Musique]
les mots fusent les idées foisonnent les
tunisiens parlent tchatche ça crie
beaucoup et ça sourit souvent ça marche
ça manifeste sa sit-in ça débat un
problème un forum un désaccord une ag
ce sont là les bons moments de la
révolution
lorsque le peuple croit que tout est
possible et quelle tolérance
[Applaudissements]
et les belges y est une intellectuelle
tunisienne
une grande dame est une écrivaine
renommée elle ausculte son pays depuis
longtemps donc il ya plusieurs tours et
lyall à l'africa oui mais l'entreprise
accéder le parti est un parti unique le
parti de ben ali
ah oui de le rcd c'est parti allez mes
pensées la maison du top 100 mais non
seulement profiter oui c'est pas
totalement comment dire extravagant que
la révolution est lui en tunisie il ya
eu un travail sur les libertés privées
vous savez qu'à libertés publiques ça
commence là ça commence à la maison
quand à table on peut parler avec ses
parents quand on sait c'est la liberté
et bien ce travail a commencé depuis 50
ans et il a abouti moi je crois que
c'est ça aussi la révolution pour sa vie
la surrection ça a été le commentaire
l'explosion visible mais les causes
invisible elles sont multiples il ya une
causalité multiples l'état moi je dis
que l'état a expulsé ben ali et dire que
ben ali n'a pas pu [ __ ] en l'air si je
puis me permettre l'état exactement
les gens qui ont plié qu on obéit qui
ont servi l'état ils ont continué à
faire leur boulot ils ont tenu les
hôpitaux ils ont dirigé des services de
médecine exemplaires ils ont enseigné
ils ont formé ils ont diffusé des textes
de philosophie de sociologie tous ces
gens là ils l'ont fait en étant
silencieux avec une très grande
discrétion très grande modestie mais ils
ont fait leur métier d'instituteur si
j'ose dire de la république celui qui
transmet les valeurs et moi je crois que
c'est parce que l'état est resté ce
qu'il est que ben ali c'est l'état tout
en tics a expulsé le corps malade du
pouvoir la presse en général et l un des
auxiliaires du pouvoir totalement
contrôlé corsetée aux ordres tout ce qui
pouvait ressembler aux médias étaient
soumis au clan ben ali
la voix de ben ali s'est exercée depuis
cette horrible bâtiment carré aussi
monumental que notre maison de la radio
à paris dans les studios et les couloirs
on réapprend le journalisme mais d'abord
voici un best of de la télé tunisienne
telle qu'elle était avant
[Musique]
2010 encore une nouvelle année de
progrès de réformes politiques sur la
voie de la démocratie et de la diversité
c'est réparable
une nouvelle année de réalisation du
programme du président zine el abidine
ben ali qui vient d'affirmer le
renforcement des réformes politiques
pour garder notre avis la diversité de
la presse traduit son attachement à la
diversité d'opinion la diversité
d'opinion représentent à ses yeux un
droit de l'homme fondamental
yamine djerroud prinsen la femme arabe a
trouvé sa voie en la personne de la
première dame de tunisie
madame ben ali présidente de
l'association de la femme arabe ou une
voix qui a touché les coeurs et les
esprits
interview - battus et celui qui relève
les défis induits le présent et tué
l'avenir want tuer celui qui va changer
la vie des gens
dès demain une reding l'avenir est avec
toi au présent
fall moustakbal omar karamé nous allons
relever le défi les bouddhas fatigue
était et notre jeunesse je vais en
récolter les fruits
maxime olli rehn
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les fruits ont pourri depuis peu dans le
hall de la télévision quelques confrères
autrefois placardisé bayonnais n'ont pu
s'empêcher de faire une croix sur les
stars du petit écran des plus inféodée
au dictateur
[Musique]
la nouvelle rédaction de la première
chaîne apprend la liberté pas simple
elle est pour l'instant en autogestion
une rédaction en chef de sept membres a
été élu
aujourd'hui c'est moufida qui dirige la
rédaction
les nouveaux présentateurs et
présentatrices on peut passer des
castings sans être obligé de bakchich et
ou de coucher ça fait longtemps vous
présentez journal demande donc la
présentatrice de la période
révolutionnaire
on peut dire ça ou pas ils ont la chance
qu'ils vont avoir la chance de vivre une
information autre que c'est une habitude
[Musique]
à l'époque de ben ali
vous auriez plus présenter le journal
non non j'ai pas pu pourquoi il ya deux
problèmes ici en division 6 jan
il ya des difficultés de faire un
casting à l'est déjà en sueur ça urge à
aux actes en attente d'un cours d'eau
[Musique]
en ouverture l'agitation politique et
sociale et notamment une grève dans les
transports publics
bien sûr ce qui se passe à la frontière
libyenne inquiète notamment les teams
and doom tout mireille doha elle est
prête à partie à la misère et la barre
des
conférence critique du jt on vient de
voir dans le journal de 14 heures un
sujet sur la grève ou en tout cas
l'arrêt des bus est ce que c'est un
sujet qui aurait pu passer à l'époque de
ben ali n'ont jamais jamais pourquoi
parce qu'à l'époque de ben ali en parler
ni de grève ni de rien parce que la
télévision n'étaient pas publics ses
terrines télévision de l'état s'étaient
eux mêmes au pire que ça c'était pas une
télévision de l'état cité la télévision
de ben ali
mais lorsque ben ali est tombée est-ce
qu'il ya eu au sein de la télévision une
épuration
est ce qu'il ya des membres de
télévision des responsables la
télévision qui ont dégagé oui bien sûr
bien et en à genève en jour dans la
rédaction aussi en absolument là
justement n'a on a fait justement un sit
in pendant deux jours et on a refusé que
l'administration se mêle de contenu du
journal et du conducteur
donc c'est pour ça qu'ont ils à
aujourd'hui on s'est mis d'accord sur
une ligne éditoriale que on est en train
de respecter et c'est le segment votre
ligne éditoriale c'est de donner la vie
et l'avis contraire à les mettre au
milieu des clubs théologie et de faire
très attention pour éviter au maximum
les dérapages
la dernière question il quelle est votre
principale inquiétude pour l'avenir
moi j'ai peur parce que en 87
on avait repris espoir après un
désespoir
là on a peur parce que rien n'est encore
gagné pour le moment mais on a de
l'espoir quand même parce que les
tunisiens sont là la casbah elle est là
pour contrôler justement ce qui va se
passer et l'espagne avait pas les
télévisions satellitaires y avait pas
facebook y avait pas les réseaux sociaux
donc moi j'ai beaucoup d'espoir j'ai pas
peur je crois que ça en vient à nous
tous d'être vigilants et
et d'imposer cette liberté pour qu'il
n'ya pas y aurait pas de recul donc on
pourra plus empêcher la parole grâce aux
nouvelles technologies
autre outil pour combattre et ces
nouveaux outils internet les réseaux
sociaux facebook
les jeunes ont su les utiliser d'une
façon incroyablement efficace voici
sofiane belhadj pendant toute la période
révolutionnaire
il avait un pseudo le cyber dissidents a
pris des risques énormes et s'il passe
aujourd'hui devant le ministère de
l'intérieur la tête haute
ça n'a pas toujours été le cas le 6
janvier dernier il a été arrêté
des images qui avait fait il est vrai
des images de torture au moment où je me
rapprochais de ce bâtiment là et le
moment je suis rentré dedans moi c'était
fini je pensais pas que j'allais pouvoir
retrouver la liberté le site oh ça m'a
permis de prendre conscience de ce que
j'avais fait parce que
à l'époque je faisais les choses je
faisais à ma petite échelle chez moi sur
mon bureau
nouveau mon ordinateur je pensais pas
que ça aurait eu autant d'impact disons
qu'une arrestation
quelque chose comme ça bon c'était
terrible sur le moment etc
mais ça permettait d'avoir un jalon dans
la cyberdissidence et donc c'était un
peu le but recherché aussi d'aller
chercher tellement loin que deviendrait
la limite
ennemi public numéro un côté vie ce que
le côté joué avec le feu jouer avec une
dictature
c'est ça qui était stimulant mais les
blogueurs ont gagné idées nouvelles lieu
de manif dénonciation des tortionnaires
enquête sur la fortune indûment gagnées
du clan ben ali grâce à eux une immense
toile a été tissée dans toute la tunisie
elle a joué un rôle primordial pour
déjouer les polices secrètes
rassemblement ce jour là pour honorer le
premier blogueur mort en 2005 à 36 ans
d'une crise cardiaque après un passage
dans les geôles de ben ali
moi personnellement j'ai commencé moi
mon activisme suite à l'histoire du
joaillier les rues parce que je me suis
dit c'est un gouvernement en vient à
traquer un jeune homme qui essaie de
parler de s'exprimer librement sur
internet c'est bien que cet outil
dangereux peut être utilisé à bon
escient et en continuant ce combat là
les cyberdissidents communiquer avec des
pseudos et sans se rencontrer le pseudo
de sofiène hamadi kaloutcha
un ami de hamadi kaloutcha donc
depuis très longtemps est enfin tu viens
de me connaître c'est la première fois
qu'on sera en direct et on a pas mal
d'écoles ça facebook ces réseaux sociaux
etc
ils nous ont permis à tous les tunisiens
de se dire non en fait c'est pas moi qui
en ai marre dans mon coin c'est tout le
monde c'est une généralité et en fait on
nous hue journaux opinion pour en faire
la propagande officielle où tout le
monde très heureux et content de ce qui
se passe dans le pays et c'est du temps
de ben ali
surfer sur internet dans un cybercafé
c'était un risque le gouvernement
disposer d'outils de contrôle
sophistiqué
les gérants des cybercafés devait
utiliser des logiciels espions
vous devez l'acheter ou vous le donner
il existe et les sur internet on lui dit
richard ellis et comme par hasard et les
morts comme par hasard
le moose la couleur de bonal et auteur
était un repas aux mauves quasiment du
temps de ben ali les bleus
c'est bien cool on va aller 20 c'est le
rouge nationale bientôt ces drames
en plus de ça dans les postes il
il traque tous les sites web qui ont été
censurés non utilisé par le client
duhamel fait du tracking acheter nous
dormirons conçoit et ben ça leur a servi
beaucoup et les généalogies sienne
résultats on les a eus avec internet
c'est clair qu'il y avait la police
politique etc mais une grande partie la
plus grande partie c'était dans la tête
c'était la méfiance les uns des autres
entre temps se connecter pour faire une
petite manipulation par les politiques
se méfier de la personne qui était à
côté c'était potentiellement un fixe
était parce que c'était ça le le régime
ben ali
ça a été un bluff ou coup de bluff on
est là tout le monde est en train de
paisibles le mans de chatter sur le net
à naître où il ya plus de censure on
l'entend le talent c'est en train de
discuter des discussions politiques
tout ça c'est ça c'est différent c'est
nouveau c'est faire la différence
je sais pas il y à un état qu'on ne
pourrait pas décrire mais c'est comme
une capsule sur la tête s'est ouvert un
étau
c'est votre bureau vous êtes en
c'est c'est un style de ministres
révolutionnaire ça c'est mon style et je
pense qu'il vaut mieux que la fonction
change onu que je change moi on sait la
part qu'a eu internet donc dans la
révolution
mais aujourd'hui quel peut être le rôle
d'internet
il va falloir prépa préparer le terrain
pour ces élections est la seule manière
de le faire c'est le débat public est
donc là c'est là où intervient internet
c'est à dire maintenant on a plus de 2
millions de tunisiens sur internet
c'est-à-dire 20% de la population par
exemple la sur la constitution voilà
j'espère bien qu'il y aura un débat sur
ce qu'il faut mettre dans la
constitution et le débat est déjà là
c'est quoi une constitution
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qu'une
constituante
c'est quoi le rôle d'une constitution qu
est ce qu il faut mettre qu'est ce qu'il
faut pas mettre les pour les contre etc
[Musique]
tout près du palais de justice les
trottoirs sont encombrés d'avocats en
robe plus fier que jamais de la porte et
ils ont eu un rôle déterminant dans les
événements
à deux pas le ministère de l'éducation
nationale
et là ça râle et ça trépigne d centaine
de profs dont certains campent sur les
trottoirs depuis des semaines réclament
tout simplement leur dû un poste
d'enseignant mais voilà son pistant sans
argent pour graisser la patte au chef
comme sous l'ancien régime
aucune chance d'y parvenir tout se fait
grâce à l'argent on embauche les profs
qu'avec de l'argent on embauche les
fonctionnaires qu'avec de l'argent
vous croyez qu'on n'a pas les preuves
nous on n'a pas de piston mais
aujourd'hui nous on a les preuves
écrites de sa des papiers qui viennent
tout droit d'ici du ministère et tout ça
continue même après le 14 janvier des
militants ont tourné avec un téléphone
portable et une caméra cachée
ils ont infiltré les corrompus
voilà quelques jours un agent du
ministère a accepté de l'argent en
échange de l'attribution d'un poste à un
enseignant le délinquant est en taule
depuis paraît-il mais la colère des
profs demeure l'assainissement n'est
vraiment qu'à ses tout débuts
est ce que vous avez eu des assurances
de la part du nouveau ministre par
exemple non qui vous a dit bon voilà on
a la preuve alors maintenant on va
arrêter ça non il n'est pas là monsieur
le nouveau ministre et monsieur taieb
baccouche et n'est pas là il n'est pas
là et en tant que personne
c'est un type nice où ils n'entendent
rien d'accord vraiment sur ce qui a
changé avec la révolution mais bien sûr
c'est pour ça qu'on est là
c'est ce que vous croyez pas qu'il faut
un peu de temps aussi parce que il va y
avoir un sourire charge me suis ici on
va mourir
on a tous des problèmes de santé lui
conteste mal encore il va réagir
il va réagir quand ça va mal trois jours
c'est pénible de vivre et c'est avec ces
conditions misérables
attention c'est dégagé mais bien sûr et
doit dégager va pas rester ici
dégage le mot clé de la révolution
tous voudraient faire table rase du
passé vite très vite et c'est bien là le
hic les chômeurs diplômés et les plus
démunis auront-ils la patience
d'attendre le changement de mentalité
c'est une nécessité et futures
obligations pour le nôtre pays chance
pour notre pays évolue déjà créé le
meilleur aux pensées acquis qui ne
changent pas de mentalité pour les
cadres les cadres ils doivent
essentiellement changer leurs mentalités
changer leurs modes de vie changent et
même l'entourage de travail et pour
telle autre c'est parce que c'est très
intéressant des côtes et une nouvelle
mentalité on a une nouvelle montre et je
comprends ça mais on va avoir des postes
mais je comprends donc votre problème
c'est la mentalité c'est bien mais votre
problème c'est le travail quand même si
je travaille si je travaille sexiste
l'accord fixe y gymnase une idée si
j'existe donc je participe si je
participe donc je change
si je change donc si j'ai fait quelque
chose que moi je voulais vraiment que je
veux ici à la tunisie la course de
vitesse est engagée romantisme contre
réalisme
ce n'est pas parce que le couvercle de
la cocotte minute a sauté que la soupe
doit rester la même
m'a dit aux tunisiens il faut il faut
pas mentir le premier ministre lui est
optimiste alors le problème de la
corruption c'est fini et je sais que
c'est vrai je sais c'est fini comme ça
parce que d'abord moi à oui oui mais
comment faire lorsque ya quand même
beaucoup bien sûr que son prix est ce
que c'est vrai l'habitude est une
seconde nature landais mais c'est la
quête qui donne l'exemple ci parce que
sinon il n'y a pas de raison c'est celui
qui t'a aux corrompus tous ces corrompus
donc jusqu'à maintenant en tout cas il
ya un coup d'arrêt et de toute façon à
la pratique
les gens vont comprendre que ce
phénomène existe
il n'y a pas de prélèvements au culte et
qu'il n'y a pas de filière pour arriver
à avoir un projet etc
c'est fini il faut rétablir l'état dans
sa dignité et de sa fonction essentielle
terrasse et la corruption
on verra reste l'autre grand chantier du
gouvernement provisoire
la remise en marche de l'économie
direction redeyef à 400 km au sud-ouest
de tunis tu sais montagne recèle la
principale richesse du pays
le phosphate c'est le moteur économique
de la région
tout le monde ici vite au rythme de la
mine au coeur du bassin redeyef une
ville rebelle une ville symbole c'est
dans cette petite commune de 30000
habitants que s'est joué le premier acte
de la révolution tunisienne
au printemps 2008
quatre personnes y sont mortes dans des
affrontements avec la police
le mouvement est parti de ce local
syndical ou le portrait du dictateur
déchu sert désormais de paillasson
la compagnie des phosphates truquée
comme partout les concours de
recrutement
cette année-là mille candidats se
présentent pour 80 postes
seuls les proches du pouvoir sont
embauchés tout le bassin minier se
soulève à leur tête
ces syndicalistes c'est ici qu'on a
brisé le mur de peur et on a cassé le
mieux de silence
il leur a fallu du courage à ces hommes
et ces femmes pour descendre dans la rue
et brandir des banderoles le seul
journaliste qui a couvert ce printemps
de redeyef et filmé ces images qui sont
passés entre les filets des censeurs de
ben ali a payé le prix fort à damas km
cela m'a valu d'être condamné à 4 ans
est enfermé pendant plus de six mois
et s'il n'y avait pas eu cette
révolution par le peuple tunisien je
serai encore détenus pendant six mois
les révoltés de redeyef tiennent tête à
dix mille policiers 300 personnes sont
arrêtés jugés et emprisonnés
trois ans de cauchemar et de harcèlement
policier pour les leaders du syndicat
j'ai été victime de différentes sortes
de tortures j'ai été frappé à coups de
bâton sur les mains et sur la plante des
pieds
il y a eu aussi des coups de pied et des
sévices au visage en particulier les
yeux avec la ligne rouge était sur le
sol et commencer à se faire du saut en
hauteur et sa terry sa terrible la
tireuse c'est encore mon cassé deux
côtes
on m'a arraché des cheveux
à l'époque j'avais des cheveux longs et
puis s'amusait à chauffer des menottes
avec des briques est libérée en novembre
2009 grâce à la pression internationale
ces militants dont beaucoup sont
enseignants ont été réintégrés dans leur
travail qu'après la révolution
adele est le premier à avoir repris ses
cours d'histoire au lycée sur wii
oui je suis très très très très cellules
mortes où on travaille à museler
mais l'ancien relais
nation mes collègues aussi le statut
social
vous êtes tous contents que le prof en
revenus
l'aca
[Musique]
petite surprise des élèves à leur prof
ils ont détourné la page 114 de leurs
manuels d'histoire
[Musique]
papa
ben ali n'est plus qu'un mauvais
souvenir
mais reste l'envers du miracle
économique tunisien tant vanté par la
dictature
le chômage est la principale
préoccupation dans le bassin minier dans
la montagne les bulldozer de la
compagnie des phosphates sont à l'arrêt
l'extraction du minerai bloqué par des
chômeurs qui réclament des emplois
ce petit groupe d'or sous la tente et
barrent la route aux engins depuis un
mois
nous demandons à la compagnie de nous
trouver un travail digne
on nous a envoyé plusieurs personnes
mais ils ne nous ont pas encore trouvé
de solution
avec la révolution la situation s'est
ouverte nous voulons que l'état nous
comprenne
nous sommes pauvres et nous avons besoin
de leur méthode est simple mais efficace
à quelques-uns ils forment une chaîne et
empêche tout trafic sur la piste
en faire venir nos familles aussi on
peut faire venir nos familles
elle peut venir à tout moment petits et
grands pour faire la grève avec nous il
faut que les gens de la compagnie
viennent nous proposer un travail ici
sinon ils devront nous mettre en prison
on nous tuer
conséquence du blocage des sites
d'extraction et des grèves chez les
transporteurs l' usine de phosphate de
redeyef est arrêté depuis deux mois plus
de matière première pour la fabrication
d'engrais ou de lessive
les stocks de minerai noir s'entassent
et les pertes s'accumulent pour la
compagnie
les ouvriers eux entretiennent leur
outil de travail
cette entreprise ne profite pas qu'à
nous les travailleurs mais à beaucoup de
gens a toute la tunisie et c'est aussi
de l'économie
il paraît qu'on perd l'équivalent de 3
milliards de dinars par jour
on a perdu des marchés et pas mal de
choses la révolution n'est pas encore
finie on n'a encore rien gagné
en réalité on n'a rien vu de cette
révolution
[Musique]
le rêve le dispute à l'urgence c'est ce
qui m'éclate à la figure depuis que je
parcours le pays
il y avait officiellement cinq cent
mille chômeurs en tunisie avant la
révolution
en juin ils seront sept cent mille les
jeunes ont été sacrifiés exclus du
marché de l'emploi
pestiféré dans leur propre pays un jeune
diplômé sur quatre est au chômage
tunis regorge de ces sans travail qui si
rien n'est fait évidemment de viendront
chez nous des sans papiers je suis
retourné dans le quartier denis là où
les gardes nationaux m'avait emmené pour
me faire part de leurs nouveaux
comportements face à la population sans
eux cette fois j'ai rencontré ou le
jeunesse en plein désarroi depuis quand
depuis une dizaine d'années et j'ai deux
enfants et travaillez vous êtes chômeur
depuis combien de temps
depuis ma naissance je suis au chômage
personne ne m'a jamais fait travailler
le café toute la journée
certains pour ne pas dire tous ont envie
de partir de quitter le pays
révolution ou pas depuis la la
révolution vous préférez rester ici où
vous voulez quand même partir à
l'étranger
oui aujourd'hui demain si on pouvait ne
resterait pas ici tout le monde veut
partir parce que ce n'est pas un pays si
si on avait notre dignité ici c'est
comme si ce n'était pas notre pays nous
sommes comme des étrangers chez nous
alors pourquoi ne pas devenir étranger
ailleurs on ne trouve rien ici mais s'il
y avait quelque chose à faire chez nous
on resterait ce serait mieux lui c'est
le patron du bistrot lui il a sa machine
à café et derrière son zinc
il les regarde tous ces jeunes
impuissant on est passé à plusieurs
reprises devant la terrasse du café qui
a toujours les mêmes jeunes qui sont
assis qui font rien de la journée c'est
parce qu'ils sont tous au chômage je
suppose non c'est ça les jeunes que vous
voyez qu'ils sont tous les jours dans la
rue n'ont pas de business pas de boulot
y en a qui sont diplômés en finance il y
en a qui n'ont pas de diplôme il y en a
même qui sont sortis du système scolaire
que ces jeunes c'est la situation pour
continue peuvent redescendre dans la rue
faut qu'on soit patient inch'allah on
aura l'opportunité de travailler de
nouveau il faut qu'on laisse une
deuxième chance au gouvernement
je suis optimiste si on patiente un peu
ça ira mais si on attend trop et les
solutions viennent pas il ya des chances
que ça recommence
l'économie est à genoux croissance zéro
ou presque
la révolution les grèves les blocages du
sinn la fuite des touristes
le parfum de la révolution s'estompe
même si beaucoup veulent croire toujours
mahmoud baroudi est un jeune analyste
financier qui travaillent dans les
quartiers d'affaires de tunis est ce que
l'état aujourd'hui a les moyens de
répondre à ses revendications
c'est le vrai problème actuel avec
toutes les indemnisations toutes les
réparations
des dégâts dans tout ça va creuser le
déficit budgétaire de la tunisie sur
l'agitation là le taux d'endettement
très élevé en tunisie
donc en rangs pense qu'il est qu'il
avoisine les 40 8% du pib
donc ces choses là vont être la
contrainte principale
ça fait beaucoup quand même mais il ya
l'argent en tunisie aujourd'hui on a
plus ben ali on n'a plus la famille
trabelsi
on n'a plus la famille matri aujourd'hui
nous tue dix ans il peut profiter d'eux
ne cesse de sa production
on a de l'argent on s'attend à ce que
nos partenaires nos habits nous aide
qu'est ce que vous attendez comme geste
la france veut dire pas du point de vue
politique mais du point de vue
économique les français sont nos amis on
considère que la france a joué un rôle
très important dans le développement de
la tunisie
mais sa position dernièrement de
soutenir le régime de ben ali de vouloir
renvoyer aux tunisiens des bombes
lacrymogènes et sans soutien sur le plan
sécuritaire a causé beaucoup de tort à
l'image de la france chez le tunisien à
vous estimez donc que la france d'une
certaine manière vous est redevable
on attend à ce que les français
soutiennent au mois cette révolution en
vue en venant se bronzer sur nos plages
avant ils veulent et se bronzer pour que
ben ali s'en mettre plein les poches
aujourd'hui c'est le peuple excusé à qui
va s'en mettre plein les poches
ils doivent nous aider il doit venir et
soutenir au moins la côte tunisienne et
la révolution des jasmins en venant
profiter de la démocratie à la
tunisienne
avec ou sans l'aide de la france
les tunisiens sont tout entiers tournés
vers l'avenir politique de leur pays
un premier signe fort aura lieu le 24
juillet prochain le jour prévu pour
l'élection des représentants de la
future assemblée constituante
il reste trois mois pour poser les
jalons de la démocratie c'est
l'effervescence
une cinquantaine de partis politiques
ont déjà été reconnus tous attendent
l'élection mais aucun ne sait encore
quel sera le code électoral
à quoi va ressembler la deuxième
république tunisienne pour plancher
dessus une centaine de responsables
politiques de militants associatifs de
représentants de la société civile ont
été réunis dans une commission
sofien notre blogueur révolutionnaire en
fait partie désigné par le premier
ministre il ya trois mois le jeune
activiste s'était attaché menotté dans
les geôles de ben ali
aujourd'hui il est de ceux qui vont
faire la tunisie de demain
première réunion de cette nouvelle
commission c'est le président de la
république foued mebazaa qui ouvre les
débats
je suis conscient dans cette situation
particulière qui va falloir tous nous
doter d'un esprit patriotique et nous
conduire en personnes responsables pour
faire primer l'intérêt supérieur de
l'état
sofien le sait ça ne sera pas une partie
de plaisir mais il savoure aussi ses
premiers moments dans son nouveau
costume d'homme libre
les cinématiques restaurant voilà je
croyais en un idéal et je n'ai défendu
bec et ongles envers les corps
liberté ici aussi le débat fait rage
déjà au sein même de la commission des
voix s'élèvent et conteste la légitimité
de certains il faut que le premier
ministre voit sa copie et recompose
cette commission
cette commission est complètement
noyauté soit par des personnes alliées à
l'ancien régime à ces différents
appareils et à son parti dissous soit
par des personnes qui n'ont jamais pris
position
une seule fois dans leur vie contre
cette dictature
c'est une véritable mascarade il n'y a
aucune volonté politique de parvenir à
un accord sérieux et responsable
premier claquement de porte
l'heure des compromis viendra aussi en
tunisie
[Musique]
nomination des portes elle dit juste
représentation fonctions dans l'état
actuel de ses ministres
pour elle et bgi d'autres intellectuels
féministe est plutôt à gauche c'est
maintenant que se joue l'avenir du pays
on est dans la naissance de la
démocratie mais il faut qu'on fasse bien
attention parce que ça va être les
fondements et si on rate les fondements
et bien la démocratie sera perverti dès
sa naissance à dire ce sera un foetus
qui sera mal formés et il faut que dès
maintenant on soit extrêmement rigoureux
extrêmement scrupuleux de soi même je
cède à travers chacun chaque chacun
d'entre nous doit faire ce travail et
dans cette démocratie en construction
les femmes ne veulent pas être relégué
au rôle de figurante
elle compte profiter de cette période
pour obtenir une égalité totale dans la
loi comme dans les faits
oui
dans le cortège il ya les voiles et les
non voilées il ya les anciennes et les
plus jeunes elles elles sont venues à 2
la fille et la mère militante féministe
elles sont venues avec le sourire pour
exprimer leurs craintes et leurs envies
on a toujours nos revendications qui
sont la laïcité qui sont l'égalité la
démocratie et donc c'est vrai qu'on a
plus ben ali aujourd'hui mais on a
encore nos revendications qui sont pas
encore réalisé qu'on veut qu'on tient
vraiment à les réaliser à les voir la
femme tunisienne peut avoir des acquis
qu'elle a qu'elle mérite et les équipes
comme heyritz et de vivre dedans un pays
moderne dans un pays qui croit à la
légalité de la femme
dans le monde arabe la femme tunisienne
reste de loin la plus émancipées et la
mieux intégrés à la société et cela date
de bien avant cette révolution c'est en
1956 que bourguiba a pris la décision de
dévoiler les femmes dans les rues de
tunis acte iconoclaste dans le monde
arabe
[Applaudissements]
mais la liste des combats à mener pour
la femme tunisienne est encore longue
égalité devant l'emploi le divorce
l'héritage loi des ses amis rêve
en ces premiers jours de printemps d'une
révolution qui ne s'arrêterait jamais
acquis c'est vrai mais pato même dans le
monde ce quad la côte quand tout le
monde croit qu'ils qui la portaient
toutes les libertés pour la femme ce
n'est pas vrai il reste beaucoup de
chapelle reste beaucoup de lois qu'il
faut la changer en otage par exemple
mérite plus que la femme on n'est pas
égaux par rapport à l'héritage ya pas
que l'héritage moi j'étais choqué la
première fois où j'ai su que par rapport
à la loi quand une femme quitte les
lieux suite la maison l'homme il peut
porter plainte pour qu'elle revienne
ça m'a vraiment joli j'aime bien
vivre de la manière que j'ai toujours
rêvé que j'ai un emploi stable que je
pratique tournée de roi avec toute
liberté mais ma vie sexuelle
parce que aussi en tant que femmes qui
sont dans un billet plus du nom on les
touche ont touché par des morts c'est
par les traditions vous êtes pour
l'égalité totale
oui je suis pas contre en tout cas lui
reposer la question parce que c'est pas
tant que ça ça ne veut pas dire qu'on
est totalement d'aquasud accord pour
l'égalité oui pour l'aller l'égalité
successorale aussi l'héritage l'héritage
oui oui aussi mais les femmes n'ont
qu'une trouille que s'introduisent dans
la paume de la démocratie
le verre d'un fanatisme islamique qui
les rend vers et au moyen-âge pour et
les vj ce risque existe
le grand risque c'est que la nature du
régime change c'est à dire que nous
soyons plus une république où le
religieux est séparé du politique mais
où le religieux mettra son empreinte
dans les institutions et surtout dans
son texte fondamental qu'est la
constitution ça voilà nous travaillons
là tu vois l'action aujourd'hui c'est ça
les partis religieux ont autant
d'importance que ça ici j'avais
l'impression que pour l'instant il
représentait pas grand chose écoutez on
ne sait pas parce que comme vous savez
c'est tous les partis qui ont été
interdits pendant très longtemps ont été
martyrisés persécutés etc
on sait pas quelle est leur capacité
ensuite de récupérer dans la société
les gens qui se sont sentis eux aussi
persécutés et s'est martyrisé et puis
c'est une inconnue c'est d'une crainte
comment vous dire c'est ça fait partie
des inquiétudes des risques de la
démocratie direction cayron quatrième
ville sainte de l'islam fief des
islamistes tunisiens
les partisans d'un islam politique ont
eux aussi été victimes de persécutions
sous le régime de bourguiba puis sous
celui de ben ali
[Musique]
leurs leaders ont été emprisonnés
certains ont été condamnés à l'exil
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les islamistes peuvent à
nouveau vivre leurs convictions comme
tous les autres citoyens et ils ont bien
l'intention de prendre leur place dans
l'échiquier politique le parti islamiste
historique s'appelle ennahda interdit
sous ben ali il est en pleine
reconstruction
abdel fattah me et l'un de ses
fondateurs
cet avocat de 63 ans longtemps condamné
au silence est venu spécialement de
tunis à la grande mosquée de kairouan
pour y prononcer l'un de ses premiers
discours politique depuis la chute de
ben ali
un véritable événement pour les fidèles
la mosquée doit être le guide de la
nation musulmane elle doit être le
berceau de son éducation
l'école de ses enfants notre affaire à
nous les religieux ni c'est que nous ne
voulons pas nous sentir étranger chez
nous dans notre pays elle il faut que la
future constitution nous préserve contre
cela et comment peut-elle le faire au
moment de créer cette constitution il
faudra qu'il soit déclaré que la tunisie
est un état indépendant républicains et
que sa religion est l'islam et son
identité et arabes
le jour des élections
vous saurez pour qui voter et vous ne
pourrez élire que celui que vous
connaissez comme étant un bon musulman
incroyants de confiance dans votre
intérêt et dans celui de la nation ou
matinale
et
le message est clair
mais en réalité différents courants
s'affrontent
abdelfattah mourou lui s'affiche plutôt
comme un républicain modéré d'autres
partis plus extrémistes pourrait voir le
jour dans les prochaines semaines
chanter soyez les bienvenus
merci elle date 2400 à donner souvent
que non non c'est pour la première fois
depuis 30 ans non le dernier près ce que
j'ai fait c'était avant le 31 c'était en
juillet 80 ans le
le lendemain j'étais en plus isolé et
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas venu plus tôt
ici à clermont
parce que on devait fermer les les
bouches pendant le règne de monsieur ben
ali pendant 23 ans je n'ai pas pu pas
les bons non vous allez voir la première
fois je parle et vous savez j'ai l'âge
de neuf ans maintenant parce que 63
moins 50 54 ans chloé sous le règne de
bourguiba et de ben ali il me laisse
neuf ans seulement
eh ben j'ai l'âge de neuf ans maintenant
très bien vous êtes un tout jeune homme
alors bien sûr un mourou réclament une
place pour les islamistes
et après tout c'est bien normal dans une
démocratie mais il ne veut pas d'un état
laïc
comment rassurer ceux qui craignent un
retour en force des islamistes puisqu'il
ya dans ces régions pas ici mais en iran
et ailleurs quelques mots quelques
régimes où l'islam et disons le
dictatorial il faudrait les
responsabiliser c'est à dire les
associés à la vie lorsqu'on éloigné
quelqu'un en laurent irresponsable pour
pouvoir diriger les islamistes
un certain calme il faut les
responsabiliser en les associant à la
construction de la tunisie
c'est ce que je demande c'est ce que je
dis mais pourquoi ne pas vouloir un état
laïc où toutes les religions serait
respecté ça mais le problème ne se pose
pas ont une vie n'est-ce pas chevaux
jeune âge à qui on parle
c'est quand on est allé en tunisie un
peu partout il ya notamment des femmes
qui disent mais pourquoi n'y a pas un
état laïque est pourquoi il y aurait pas
évidemment la place pour tous les cultes
et toutes les religions
vous savez que c'est un faux problème
nous avons été gouvernée par une seule
constitution la constitution 59 qui
stipule l'article 1er qu'il s'agit d'un
pays dans la religion est l'islam et
pendant ces cinquante années
jamais une personne il a été obligé à ne
pas suivre sa conviction
pourquoi on arrivait à dire que cet
alpage pays laïc
est ce que vous êtes d'accord que par
exemple la loi aussi peu évolué et que
non
hamon pour les femmes qui n'ont pas les
mêmes les mêmes à tours on fait les
mêmes droits que les hommes sur la
question de l'héritage est ce que vous
êtes prêts à revenir là dessus nous
disons que les acquis de la femme
pendant les cinquante années qui sont
passés seront préservés par les
islamistes
oui mais des femmes demandent aussi une
égalité face à l'héritage que c'est quoi
ce qui concerne notre parti politique
est ce que oui ou non vous
personnellement vous êtes pour que
l'héritage soit égal à égal pour les
autres on défend l'application delà du
code de statut personnel qui a été fait
par bourguiba
je n'en saurai pas plus l'homme est
intelligent sympathique
il ne m'a pas totalement rassuré
bien sûr tous les tunisiens ou presque
semble d'accord sur le fait que la
deuxième république devra être une
démocratie mais quel chemin vont-ils
suivre
le chef du gouvernement lui y croit
jamais la démocratie ne réussira dans
d'autres pays si elle veut c'est pas en
tunisie parce que nous nous avons toutes
les conditions de réussite
nous avons une classe moyenne importante
nous avons une femme libérer
complètement nous avons un peuple
instruit la meilleure façon pour que
nous puissions avoir droit de cité dans
le monde et que le monde nous donne
crédit pour la mise en place d'un
processus démocratique
c'est qu'il a réussi cette révolution
chez nous si ça manque d'ambition
belle ambition c'est tout ce que je vous
souhaite à vous et à votre peuple
[Musique]
et